[Music]
the pandemic changed office work
more employees are working from home
than ever before
but as the world begins to recover from
covid19
should things go back to how they were
do office workers belong in the office
and where are they most productive
[Music]
now callum and and and fingers can i
just ask you how your working lives have
changed in the last 18 months and
if you think ahead sort of covered
restrictions aside what does your ideal
new work model sort of looks like i
guess like everyone really i've moved
pretty much to a full time working from
home um i'm in some i'm in san francisco
at the moment uh which is where i i live
at the moment so in terms of what i
would ideally like it's pretty much this
i suppose the only difference would be
it would be better to have more
opportunities for kind of
the sort of back and forth of ideas that
uh was more common in the days of um
100 office going and for jira what's it
been like um for you i mean if i'm not
mistaken you changed jobs in the middle
of all of this yes i actually
interviewed for this job remotely and
i'm based in the london office and i
think
a lot's been said about the difficulty
of hiring and onboarding during
lockdowns but i think i've been
pleasantly surprised by the way that
it's worked out really well you know if
you think about your first day or your
first week in a new job you're nervous
you're in a brand new building with a
brand new commute and you know you're
just trying to remember everyone's names
i think for me uh being able to do that
from a familiar setting is actually i
think taken some of that pressure off i
wondered if you could just talk us
through
how
employees are feeling and how employers
are feeling i think this has been a huge
challenge for employers and they're
definitely mismatches and expectations
you know what employers want doesn't
always align with what employees expect
and if you look at apple you know i
think that's probably been the most high
profile case
senior managers want staff to return to
the office at least three days a week
but you're seeing that employees are
really pushing back and i believe uh
there have been two petitions that have
been signed by over a thousand people
a handful of people have actually
resigned over this at apple and uh you
know some employees are speaking out
publicly and i think that's that's
really striking because to have apple
employees speaking out so publicly
against their management is almost
unprecedented for a company that's been
so fiercely private it's now becoming a
cultural norm that uh if you are working
in a what you know knowledge intensive
work white collar work basically that
you will be allowed to
spend at least some of the week at home
and a company that is saying we want
everyone in the office five days a week
we'll quite quickly run up against a
problem where
good employees say i don't want to work
here anymore today most people envision
some form of hybrid working and gartner
predicts that globally half of all
knowledge workers will be remote at
least one day a week by the end of this
year and you know of course there will
be differences in preference parents and
carers for example are more likely to
want to work from home a number of days
a week
you've got disabled workers who reported
finding remote working more accessible
what i found most striking is how
race can impact that preference and this
is still an under researched area but
there was one report by slack which
showed that just three percent of
knowledge workers black knowledge
workers in america
wanted to return to the office full time
now that's compared to 21 of their white
counterparts a lot of workers are
talking about you know
not just of good work life balance but
also actually a really productive time
whereas quite a few employers
particularly those who are calling for
people to come back a lot seem to think
that actually you do need to physically
be somewhere to be productive the best
mix is not everyone in the office all
the time and it's also not everyone at
home all the time it's sort of a bit of
both um and that is because quite simply
you can have a more efficient division
of labor of your working week if you do
it that way so say for instance if i'm
working from home two days a week
on those two days i can do the tasks
that really require me to be like by
myself concentrating not interrupted and
and so on so i can do those on monday
and friday and on tuesday wednesday and
thursday i can do the kind of tasks that
um that require collaboration with
others should it just be left to workers
to figure out
how much they individually want to come
in or is it actually from an employer's
point of view more helpful to say
everyone should come in on a tuesday and
a thursday or everyone in this team
should come in on tuesday and thursday
and beyond that you know see for
yourself teams choosing which days they
want to come in uh is actually quite
helpful and i think it's something that
solves the issue of hybrid meetings you
know which could be a really big
challenge uh already we're seeing that
there's a lack of consensus around which
meetings people should hold in person
and which ones uh people should keep
virtual i mean something i'm hearing
more about over here is is the idea of
mandating days when you're not allowed
to come into the office
uh so you actually are you you must work
from home on tuesday for instance and
the reason the reason for that is
because um
it's sort of to try and overcome the
biases in sort of uh promotion and and
and that kind of thing that you might
get otherwise the original study on this
of which was done by on the chinese call
center workers showed that even if
people were equally productive
merely going into the office was enough
to get yourself a promotion basically
which is which is bad really
i think the challenge now for companies
is to try to find a middle ground that
works for all of their employees but
more crucially one that works for the
companies themselves
hi this was part of a digital event
produced exclusively for subscribers to
the economist if you'd like to watch the
full discussion of this or of one of our
other events then click the link you'll
just have to register if you haven't
already or you can become an economist
subscriber to enjoy access to all of our
journalism thanks for watching